I found 30 000 liters of milk and it
breaks my heart an Ontario Dairy Farmer
pouring raw milk down the drain
Jerry wiegen making a point in this
controversial video
and no matter how we stand up but this
time I'm going public he has a lot of
courage to do what he did Wigan says he
reached his milk quota under Canada's
Supply management system there's no
incentive when you've delivered your
limit they're just being asked to dump
and they dump that's all they do make it
illegal and then find a new market for
your surpluses this dump is a drop in
the bucket Dairy Farmers around the
country dump anywhere between 100
million to 300 million liters a year the
public doesn't understand the quota
system another Dairy Farmer put out a
video criticizing Wigan by doing what
you did you're going against your own
not good not cool the regime that we
have in Canada wants to maintain uh milk
prices at a high level in an email to
Global News Dairy Farmers of Ontario
told us the system offers a sustainable
approach to milk production for
consumers processors and Farmers by
ensuring the supply of milk aligns with
consumer demand milk price is went up
2.2 percent this month I think they have
to reevaluate that
to do what do you think of throwing away
perfectly good milk because
they produce too much what do you think
about that and food wasters in general
is like a big deal right that we have to
start taking steps to prevent them
instead it's down the drain a liquid
waste at a time when millions of
Canadians are struggling to buy food
Sean O'Shea Global News